jack dorsey square spiral and lightning
development kit yes jack dorsey who
recently stepped down as a twitter ceo
he is focusing much more time on square
square has a brand new division that's
been renamed it's called spiral they
published a video yesterday that is
showcasing the capabilities of bitcoin
lightning and a lightning development
kit an ldk this is super important
because when you create these
development kits it allows all sorts of
different developers around the world to
start to actually build on top of
lightning so what exactly is spiral
spiral is the subsidiary spiral was
previously known as square crypto
they've been developing bitcoin wallet
solutions since it was founded in 2019
they used to be called square crypto but
recently changed the name we have off
their website once square decided to
rebrand we knew it was time for our own
long overdue rebrand after all square
crypto was never the best name for our
team and on the other hand having crypto
in his name led to confusion as the
company is focused solely on bitcoin
itself so when you start to think about
this then you ask yourself what exactly
is the ldk the lightning development kit
well here are the goals of the lightning
development kit one it has been designed
to allow developers to seamlessly plug
their applications into the network on
mobile devices and point of sale
terminals this lets developers customize
their wallet app for their users in the
language of their choice while also
removing the necessity for separate
bitcoin and lightning network wallets on
top of the ldk spiral is also working on
a number of other things like a bitcoin
development kit which allows
cross-platform mobile wallet
interactions and they're doing all this
because bitcoin adoption is growing and
lightning network adoption is growing as
well we have seen a massive increase the
number of lightning nodes running on the
network which allows for more capacity
on the network as well you can see this
chart it's beautiful we just continue to
go up and to the right in a very
aggressive way on top of that we've also
seen the lightning network increase the
capacity the more can scale bitcoin
transactions and increase its use case
as a day-to-day payment system we
continue to see that go up and to the
right as well jack dorsey square and now
spiral all going in on the lightning
network and creating developer tools are
we bullish on this or do we think that
there's a lot more work to do
bullish why
because
jack dorsey's goaded
like simple as that everything he
everything he seems to work on does
really well right he's built up massive
companies um spiral recently renamed
from square crypto to kind of more
aligned with they're all focused on
bitcoin and not cryptocurrency so it
makes a lot of sense that um they're
launching this product i'm curious to
see where this product kind of ends up
in like a product market fit and if
people actually use it right because i
know they went after hardware wallets
they've gone after a few different
things but it's payment solutions for
bitcoin which i think is the biggest um
kind of open end right now with bitcoin
the other thing that i'm really
interested in is how many developers are
actually going to adopt this and once
they start to adopt it what is the
actual impact uh of it if you make it
easier for developers to develop on top
of bitcoin then i think that they will
do it and that ultimately leads to more
value accruing to bitcoin and lightning
does it get more people involved in the
development though absolutely yeah
that's the key yeah of course